une décision qui ne relève pas du droit
mais de la politique c'est avec ces mots
que le responsable de la radio echo de
moscou dénonce la récente décision de
fermer leurs médias l'un des rares
indépendant russie le rédacteur en chef
assure que dans le pays on vit désormais
dans un quasi état de guerre mais refuse
d'arrêter de travailler tant que la
police ne les aura pas fait taire de
force
je m'en fous je me fiche de savoir
comment se sentent les journalistes
leurs obligations elle travaillait il ne
travaille pas pour les actionnaires ni
l'état il travaille pour les auditeurs
les auditeurs se fiche de la santé du
journaliste de l'interdiction de radio
de la maladie de son enfant de la météo
le journaliste a l'obligation de travail
on est de fournir des informations des
opinions des conversations t16 tuning
est baissière des talibans la radio a
fait appel de la décision
l'équipe peine à croire que le tribunal
tranchera en sa faveur mais refuse de
céder à la panique tant que l'équipement
les ordinateurs sont là dit il c'est
qu'il reste un espoir
notre mode de fonctionnement dépendra
des circonstances bien sûr le gardien
peut venir à tout instant avec ses clefs
et verrouiller la rédaction tout
simplement annuler nos badges mais tout
le monde est prêt à continuer de
travailler
la liberté de la presse déjà mise à mal
par le kremlin ces dernières années est
de plus en plus malmenés en russie
depuis le déclenchement de la guerre en
ukraine les autorités ne tolèrent pas la
moindre diffusion d'informations qui
n'auraient pas été validée en haut lieu
une propagande d'état pour tenter de
manipuler l'opinion et lui cacher les
raisons de la guerre et ses premières
conséquences parfois tragiques sur
l'armée et l'économie russe